11:6 19 yesterday's date a date that
will live in infamy as I stand now in
the aftermath of yesterday's tragedy
surveying the wreckage I have trouble
making sense of it understanding it and
I think like a lot of people we're just
trying to get on our feet again and and
move forward and not even understanding
which way is forward in the in the haze
of this tragedy the news reported by
outlets across the world Daily Mail Fox
News ABC NBC they were all on top of the
story Miley Cyrus and Liam Hemsworth
unfollowed each other on Instagram
according to a report in People magazine
this is the latest says almost three
months after announcing their separation
fans have noticed exes Miley Cyrus and
Liam Hemsworth have seemingly unfollowed
each other on Instagram now while it's
unclear when the two made the split
social media official or who first made
the move
Cyrus 26 still follows Liam's brother
Chris Hemsworth and Liam 29 I know now
your question is does Liam follow Miley
Cyrus's family Billy Ray Cyrus yes he
still does both stars also have left
their old posts that featured the two of
them together the posts are still there
so there's a lot we don't know and early
reports often with these things are
misleading so you want to be careful
about that but what we know for sure is
that they no longer follow each other
and two of the iconic instagramers of
our time have gone their separate ways
never to follow each other again most
likely never to like another post never
to comment on another pic never to leave
another emoji we have now only the
memory of what once was and a hole in
our hearts and a hole in society in our
culture that will never truly be filled
okay onca lessor on to lessor news the
story about ABC and Jeffrey Epstein well
ABC after being exposed for of course
squashing the Epstein story suppressing
it for three years
so not just we should remember this it's
now it's not just that they killed the
story one time it was this was according
to to wrote to the reporter who
accidentally revealed all this to the
public this was an ongoing effort by
them to suppress this story over the
course of three years but ABC now is
doing some real investigative work not
into Epstein no they're not gonna do
that but into the person who exposed
them that's what they're investigating
now before we get into this before we
get into the latest I think let's go
back in case you didn't see this clip
but even if you did I think we should
play it again to refresh our memories
and this is just something we shouldn't
forget I think that we should just play
that this should be played every day so
we remember what what the media is
really all about so let's go back and
play this video that was was released by
Project Veritas James O'Keefe this is
the video of the ABC reporter revealing
the conspiracy by ABC to suppress the
news about Epstein I've had the story
for three years I've had this interview
with Virginia Roberts we would not put
it on the air first of all I was told
who's Jeffrey Epstein no one knows who
that is this is a stupid story then the
palace found out that we had her whole
allegations about Prince Andrew and
threatened us a million different ways
we were so afraid we wouldn't be able to
interview Kate and will that we that
also quashed the story and then and then
Alan Dershowitz was also implicated in
because of the planes up she told me
everything she had pictures she had
everything she was in hiding for 12
years we convinced her to come out we
convinced her to talk to us
it was unbelievable what we had Clinton
and we had everything
I for three years to get it on to no
avail and now it's all coming out and
it's like these new relevance and I
freaking had on all of it I I'm just so
pissed right now like every day I get
more and more pissed cuz I'm just like
oh my god we it was on what what we had
was unreal other women backing it up
hey yep Brad Edwards the Attorney three
years ago saying like aunt like we there
will come a day where we will realize
Jeffrey Epstein was the most prolific
pedophile this country has ever known
and I had it all three years ago by the
way ABC has mostly tried to ignore all
of this publicly most of the mass media
has also mainly ignored the story well
they've paid it minimal attention they
basically done the bare minimum and
that's what the media does with stories
they don't like where they they don't
want to be in order if they could they
would just not report it at all but they
know they can't get away with that so
they reported a little bit and then they
can always point to that and say no we
reported it look which is why the bias
in media is often not what they report
or how they report it well there's bias
there too but it's often what they
choose not to report or how they how
they choose to stack their stories and
which stories are in the lead and which
ones are buried that's that's where you
find most of the or at least the most
sort of insidious forms of bias and
media but not only do we have media
ignoring this story for the sake of ABC
but also in some cases actively running
cover for them brian Stelter is the
media reporter over at CNN he's the
media reporter his job is to report on
the media to cover stories about the
media and yet this story broke I think
of what was it on Monday was on Tuesday
I think and it took him all day he was
tweeting about a bunch of other things
but took him all day to even acknowledge
that this story was going on which is
kind of like considering this is the
biggest media story of the year biggest
of the decade arguably a very big story
this is kind of like if you're a the the
sports reporter for a network and the
Superbowl is going on and you you're
tweeting about stuff you don't even
acknowledge it but Stelter
at the end of the day on the day that it
broke he released a newsletter where he
finally acknowledged it for the first
time but he he put it is the last thing
he covered in his newsletter let me but
what he's doing here is he's actually
covering for so he's not really covering
the stories covering for ABC so here's
what we read part of his newsletter
anyway it says Vox is Jane coasting
reports yes of course he gives us boxes
he gives us the report from Vox on this
story obviously and then it summarizes
the story he says in the video robach
clearly thinks she's just speaking
privately to a colleague what she is
heard describing is roughly what NPR's
david full conflic full conflic that's
his name great name David Falk inflict
that that is a dangerous name to say I
don't say that too many times it's a
dangerous name to say too many times on
the air David feau conflic NPR's David
Falcon flick reported earlier this year
that ABC interviewed the woman who was
accusing Epstein and in 2015 but decided
not to air the tape Falcon flicks story
suggested that lawyers including Alan
Dershowitz were involved in scuttling
the planned segment and then he says
robach put out a statement saying that
she was disappointed the interviewed in
air but she said that but she
acknowledged that it didn't meet our
standards that was her after this video
came out now she's saying that oh yeah I
mean I I I'm disappointed in there but
it didn't meet our journalistic
standards yeah well that's not what she
said in the tape that is not she didn't
you you saw the tape for yourself she
didn't say anything about well it didn't
meet her journalistic standards she was
very clear that it did meet journalistic
standards it was corroborated it was a
good story and I didn't run it Stelter
can continues nonetheless Tuesday's
video clip caused widespread widespread
outrage particularly on the right with
many commenters using it to stoke hatred
of the media writ large personally the
most troubling part for me is Epstein's
usage of high-profile high-priced lawyer
to intimidate news outlets ABC News
executives say they're journalists were
simply not able to corroborate the
details of the reporting sufficiently
for broadcast Falcon flick wrote in his
story on Tuesday okay so Stelter is
taking ABC's excuses at face value he's
giving us full conflic version and one
of his main concerns is the hatred of
the media that is being engendered by
this story the hatred from the dreaded
rut right wing commenters that's his
concern now it gets worse though yesh
our ally is a journalist who's worked
for various different outlets and he's
been following this story this week let
me read it some of a tweet thread from
him with some breaking news in it first
from last night he's it says ABC News
execs believe they know who the former
employee is who accessed footage of the
reporter expressing her frustrations
about her shell Jeffrey Epstein story
the former employee is now at CBS and
ABC execs have reached out to CBS about
that employee and then in a statement
ABC News says we take violations of
company policy very seriously and we're
pursuing all avenues to determine the
source of the leak isn't squashing a
good story because you don't want to get
Democrats and the royal family in
trouble that's not a violation of
company policy as is it at least a
violation of journalistic standards if
you have any of those and that most
recently says update to sources familiar
with the matter tell me that CBS News
has fired the staffer in question this
comes after ABC inform CBS that they had
determined who accessed the footage of
amy robach expressing her frustrations
about the Epstein story so this is this
is pretty amazing first of all you got
ABC more focused on running down the
source of the leak then addressing the
thing that was leaked namely that would
be the fact that a corroborated account
of a serial rapist and well-connected
sex trafficker was killed by ABC because
they didn't want to they were worried
about the optics for Democrats they
didn't want to destroy their access to
the royal family you know they don't
want to they wanted to have interviews
and that sort of thing
abd isn't looking into any
they just want to know who exposed them
that's the thing they're concerned about
and then they find this person working
for a different network now and that
network fires him but wait a second and
to be clear the network so CBS fired one
of their own staff for embarrassing a
rival Network but but hold on a second
isn't this staffer then a whistleblower
isn't he blowing the whistle on a major
scandal and hasn't the media spent the
last several months shouting about
protecting whistleblowers and extolling
the virtues of whistleblowers and and
and condemning anyone who outs
whistleblowers so now all of that
passion for whistleblowing is out the
window
pretty incredible this this this guy I
don't know if it's a guy or not this
person who released its footage this is
this would qualify as a whistleblower
this is a scandal it's a major scandal
and this is someone who has exposed it
and really the only way to expose it was
to release the tape because if someone
who works at CBS now the used to work at
ABC had just come out and exclaimed
asserted that ABC had the story and
killed it nobody would believe it it
could easily be deflected and denied so
the only choice was to take the footage
to take the proof and put it out there
which was the right thing to do is the
moral ethical and I think courageous
thing for this person to do putting
their own career at risk which obviously
apparently now is destroyed
that's a whistleblower so just keep this
in mind when we're talking about Trump
and and impeachment and the
whistleblower in that story every time
the media talks about protecting the
whistleblowers and everything remember
what they're doing here because when
someone blows the whistle on them now
they're gonna hunt that person down and
destroy them all right so there's this
video making the rounds on social media
a different video it's a it's a
compilation of Paulo white Paul white is
a the faith advisor to
President Trump she's also a prosperity
gospel fraud
and an embarrassment to Christianity and
a heretic
she's a pastor who's been married three
times makes millions of dollars owns a
private jet I think or used to own a
private jet lives in a mansion preaches
the most hideous mangling of the gospel
that I have ever heard and that is quite
a statement these days but her the
gospel that she preaches is is
disgusting it's revolting what she's
doing
so here's a here's a little bit of the
greatest hits compilation that's been
circulating on social media when I walk
on White House grounds God walks on
White House grounds I had every right
and authority to declare the White House
has holy ground because I was standing
there and where I stand is holy
[Music]
to say no to present Trump would be
saying out to God and there and I won't
do that we are in a spiritual war right
now let every demonic network that has
aligned itself against the purpose
against the calling of President Trump
let it be broken let it be torn down in
the name of Jesus nobody to tell you
what my thoughts are the thoughts of the
King of Kings the thoughts of the Lord
of lords I'm downloading heaven ok now
the one thing I'll say in defense of
Paulo white the one thing I'll say is
that the bit where she says saying no to
Trump is saying no to God I believe what
she's referring to her to there was her
decision to work for Trump she was
saying that I think any I think the
context was that she was saying that she
felt called to work for president robbed
God was calling her to it which he
wasn't by the way then we were pretty
sure about that I think God was calling
a heretic to go into the White House and
influence the president but she was
saying she felt called to it so to say
no to Trump would be saying no to her
calling thus saying no to God so it's
not quite as bad as it sounds but it's
still an awful and troubling way for a
so-called pastor to phrase it and but
the rest of it though is exactly what it
sounds like where she she walked where
she walks is holy ground she has the
power to sanctify any place she walks
into because she's so righteous and holy
she and you could store up favor in in
heaven by giving her money God will
bless you with material riches if you're
a good Christian and especially if you
buy her books and you give her money on
and on
Paula White is an absolute charlatan she
exploits people for money she preaches a
false gospel and she makes millions on
it it really boggles my mind that people
would go to a church but a quote-unquote
church massive scare quotes around that
I think what's the name of Richard well
she left her chair
she stepped down from a church and her
kid now is is the is the lead pastor or
something
well III read what the name of this
so-called Church is oh it's I want to
say is it city of Destiny I'm pretty
sure that's the name of her church
something like that city of Destiny or
something anyway it's it's in one sense
kind of mind boggling that people would
go to a place like this and sit and
listen to this obvious fraud bragging
about herself which is so much of her of
her against scare quotes ministry is
focused on her and how great she is
quite a ministry there but this this
unfortunately this wolf in sheep's
clothing has been elevated to a
prominent position by the president who
made her into a faith advisor and that's
what makes it all the more important for
us to denounce what she is doing and to
make it very clear that this is not
Christianity this kind of thing is so
damaging I mean a million anti-christian
zealots could not possibly do the kind
of damage to the church that people like
Paula White do they could they couldn't
possibly do it because when she's out
there as this obvious transparent fraud
and charlatan exploiting people then it
gives everyone else who's not a
Christian a chance to point to her and
say yep you know that's what
Christianity is all about it's all scam
I really hate it I really really hate it
okay speaking of things I hate there's a
movie coming out called finding Jack
it's a Vietnam War movie and the studio
behind the film has settled on one of
their lead actors for this movie that's
coming out and the lead actor is gonna
be James Dean yes the the dead one now
he died more than 60 years ago but he's
going to star in the movie and what
they're doing is they're taking old
picture
an old footage and they're gonna use it
to create a CGI version of James Dean
they're gonna have a stand-in probably
someone in what you remember you know
like Andy Serkis all the when he played
Gollum and Lord of the Rings he's
wearing the suit and they just grafted
Gollum overtop of same thing they did
with the Planet of the Apes movies that
came out so they're gonna be doing that
only with an actual human that once
lived and they're gonna be grafting him
over somebody else and they're gonna
hire a voice actor that sounds like him
we have now reached a point where
Hollywood is remaking people so if you
thought the remake and the sequel phase
was was gonna die out no it's it's you
were dead wrong so to speak it's it's
that's now they've just gone to Phase
two
now they've they've only ramped it up
not only are we gonna remake movies
we're gonna remake the people in the
movies so it's gonna get to a point and
this isn't even a joke it's gonna get to
a point where they're going to remake
you know like Gone with the Wind
with all the same actors in the original
movie who they've recreated with CGI
that's that's that's where we're headed
and it is it is utterly grotesque and
and dystopian and there are a lot of
very good actors out you know in in
Hollywood Hollywood for all of its flaws
there are a lot of really talented
people and actors I think and they would
all do a fine job acting in a Vietnam
War movie literally thousands of actors
out there would do a fine job you know
Vietnam war movie but instead of going
to one of those people one of those real
live humans they're gonna dig someone
out of the grave to do it and why is it
because it's you know because a
reincarnated fake James Dean is really
the best man for the job or fake man for
the job no it's a stunt of course it's a
stunt which exploits a dead person and
forces him to be in your movie without
his consent which is a whole separate
issue but I think this is why I think
this this kind of puts a if
Ehsan on what's martin scorsese's been
talking about and why Martin Scorsese
came out against Marvel movies the way
he did his whole point not that Marvel
has done this yet yet they'll get around
to it but his whole point was that
movies are just these days turning into
a collection of marketing stunts and
gimmicks and that's what movies are now
it's just a marketing thing and there's
no artistry to it he wrote he wrote an
article he was in the New York Times he
wrote an article a few days ago which is
worth what worth reading I think it's a
excellent article where he's fleshing
out his criticism of Marvel Marvel
movies and the one thing that he talks
about and he keeps going back to is with
real art in real films and cinema
there's there's of course artistry to it
and there's emotional risk it's like
you're you're saying something as an
artist you're putting yourself out there
and presenting something unique it's
something that is you that is from you
as an artist he talks about the you know
a real movie is comes from the vision of
the people involved and there's a sort
of single unified vision that's being
put on the screen but with these Marvel
movies in these franchise films it's not
like that this is these this is you know
you got focus groups and marketing
research and all of that it's all
tailored and stitched together to put on
the screen with the sole purpose of this
making money there's no other reason to
it like I talked about last week when
we're discussing this now I think the
the the primary purpose of a movie is
very simple it should be to tell a story
and all of the artists involved in it
their primary motivation should be to
tell this story they also want to make
money and they make a lot of it and
that's fine I don't begrudge them that
you make a billion dollars on a movie
good for you but if these if the primary
and really sole purpose of the movie was
simply just to make a billion dollars
and the story was secondary to that then
I think that's not even real movie
what's the point of you
watching it they're telling you a story
that they don't even care about the
storytellers themselves don't care about
the story they're telling you they just
want your butt in the seat so that they
can make money off you that's the only
reason and this is a perfect example of
that if you really keep you really
wanted to tell this story about the
Vietnam War I don't know what the
specific story is they're gonna tell but
there are a lot of great stories there
if you really wanted to tell a story
then you would just tell it you would
hire an actor who can do the role and
you would tell the story but instead
they're gonna make it into a grotesque
marketing stunt which we're told is okay
because James Dean's family has signed
off on it his his ancestors 65 years
later say that oh yeah sure it's a bunch
of money and put his likeness up on the
screen as if that makes it okay alright
um Matt Walsh Oh at gmail.com
Matt Walsh Oh at gmail comas email
address get to some emails this is from
Adam says I appreciate what you've said
about children having a right to a
mother and a father however as you spoke
about this issue
I heard the opposing voices screaming in
my head the studies all show that
children of same-sex couples turn out no
worse than those of traditional couples
I'm not well-versed in the literature
concerning this issue so do you know of
any studies that do support your
position on this matter yeah this is
where I think we have to be careful
about trotting out studies Adam one of
the peculiar things about debates and
discourse these days in America is that
people think they can win the argument
just by broadly citing not even citing
but simply mentioning studies without
themselves have a been it's the people
haven't read the study they're not
familiar with the methodology that went
into the study they think if they can
just say Oh studies have shown this and
maybe provide a link to a study or a
news article about the study having not
even read the news article much less the
study itself this is how debates work
these days where it's a it's a contest
of who can compile the most studies that
might vaguely sort of
educate your position but you don't even
know because you haven't read them so
yes I'm familiar with the claim that out
of the 70 or 80 studies that have been
done on children who are raised in
same-sex households the claim is that
all but a handful have found that the
kids turn out fine
now I haven't read all 80 studies okay
and I doubt that anyone has but from the
outset before I even get into any of
these studies specifically which I will
in a second from the outset my BS
detector is going haywire and I'll tell
you why before even looking at the
studies I am extremely skeptical because
first of all same-sex adoption has not
been a widespread phenomenon for very
long so if we want to know how children
turned out with same-sex parents we
would need to look at people who are now
over the age of 18 were raised by
same-sex parents that's over and now we
can look at how they turned out
the problem is that there just aren't
that many people over the age of 18 who
have been raised by the insect's parents
because it's it did it wasn't certainly
not very common 18 years ago and it's
still not very common though it's more
common now 20 years from now I think
you'll probably have a pretty large
sample size for better or worse but as
it stands right now if you want to know
how do kids turn out being raised that
way it's gonna be really difficult to
find a study that can give you relevant
results because there isn't much of a
sample size to choose from also I'm
wondering again before even looking I'm
wondering how are these studies
conducted who are they asking are they
asking the parents themselves about how
their kids are doing and if so are these
blind studies do the people involved
know that this is a study about the
effectiveness of same-sex parenting and
if they do
wouldn't that wildly skew the data if
they know if your
same-sex parent and you know that
someone is doing a study about how
effective same-sex parenting is aren't
you gonna be really biased in how you
respond to the questions and also do
these studies have a control group oh we
do we have another group that we're
comparing it to are these studies
looking at a representative
cross-section of parents in all
different socio-economic conditions
there are a lot of questions to consider
here so whenever someone talks about
studies whatever the subject is your
immediate question should be what was
the methodology how did the researchers
arrive at this conclusion just because
something is called a study doesn't
automatically mean that its findings are
compelling or even legitimate so let's
take a look here I'll give you two
examples if you google same-sex adoption
studies which is what everyone does on
this and this is how they come up with
and they and if I know 80 studies I've
been done well I googled it too and but
I took the extra step of actually
reading what some of these studies have
to say one of the first things that pops
up at least for me was it's an American
Psychological Association article so
that sounds pretty sciency and
legitimate right so on the APA org
website there's a headline that says
adopted children thrive in same-sex
households study shows okay so you've
got the APA saying there's a study that
shows shows children thrive with
same-sex parents now let's read the
article okay radical step let's actually
read the article says new research shows
that children adopted into lesbian and
gay families are as well-adjusted as
children adopted by heterosexual parents
and follow similar patterns of gender
development said Charlotte J Patterson
PhD a psychology professor at the
University of Virginia
Patterson discussed the results of a
study in in press in applied
developmental science at an APA annual
convention symposium on same-sex
marriage Patterson and co-authors Rachel
H far a psychology doctoral student at
UVA and Steven for SEL PhD a George
Washington University of George
Washington University studied 106
families including 56 same-sex couples
and 50 heterosexual couples
who adopted children at birth or in the
first few weeks of life okay it's all
sounding pretty great so far and I think
that most people when they're looking
for studies they stop right there if
they even read that far they're gonna
stop right there because okay it sounds
sciency we've got PhDs involved and okay
it all sounds great we're good to go now
already there are problems it's not a
huge sample size we're not told anything
about whether these couples represent
various socio-economic conditions or not
which will be very important for a study
like this but at least you got the
control group with the heterosexual
couples also included so okay maybe
we've got something legitimate here but
then things go wildly off rails it
continues in the study parents assess
their own parenting styles and
relationship satisfaction they also
filled out the preschoolers activities
inventory which assesses whether gender
role behavior conforms to expected
patterns or not and the excused
and the child Behavior Checklist
teachers and daycare providers were
asked to complete the caregiver teacher
report form which assesses a child's
somatic complaints anxiety depression
and withdrawn behaviors by looking at
parents self reports and reports of
others the researchers found that the
children of gay and lesbians were gays
and lesbians were virtually
indistinguishable from children of
heterosexual parents okay do you see the
massive problems here problem number one
the self reporting of parents is
basically useless parents are
notoriously biased in favor of their own
parenting and their own kids problem two
we're not told whether the parents and
the teachers knew what the study was
about did the teachers filling out the
survey know what this was what was going
on and if so wouldn't that give them an
ideological incentive to be more
generous in the answers that they
provide problem number three if these
are preschool teachers filling this
thing out are they really around the
child enough to make reliable
assessments about the child's well-being
if a teacher says that a child seems
fine as far as they can tell does that
mean the child is actually fine would
you take that as
definitive problem for and this is a big
one these apparently are preschool aged
children these are very very young
children how in God's name could you
possibly purport to prove anything about
same-sex parenting by looking at kids
who have only been in that environment
for a few years at most and who have not
who have not developed at all really
psychologically you know we need to see
this is all about their psychological
development they haven't had any
psychological development yet so what
what could you what could that possibly
preschoolers seem happy all preschoolers
seem happy have you ever been around
preschoolers tells you nothing now if a
kid seemed spying to his parents at his
teachers at the age of four that doesn't
mean he's gonna be fine at ten or twelve
or fourteen or 20 to this it's embarrass
is an embarrassingly weak study that
have all these PhDs involved and this is
what they come up with and the APA
publishes it without criticism okay so
but let's look at honey there's there's
a much touted study a much cited study
that takes a longer range view which is
what you need to do think progress has
an article about it headline kids in the
longest-running study of same-sex
parenting are doing just fine at twenty
five okay longest running study doing
just fine that sounds powerful let's
take a look the national launch into the
National Longitudinal lesbian family
study has been following a contingent of
lesbian families since they first
started to plan to have kids in the late
1980s and early 1990s those children are
now about 25 years old the researchers
have confirmed that they're doing
swimmingly compared to their peers who
are not raised by same-sex couples
researchers found no significant
differences with respect to adaptive
functioning behavioral or emotional
problems scores on mental Diagnostics
diagnostic scales or the percentage of
participants with a score in the
borderline of clinical range in short
the longest-running
study of same-sex parenting found that
kids raised by same-sex couples turn out
pretty much the same as everybody else
okay major major
major major problems here in fact this
study is garbage this study is useless
I'll put it that way and I had to look
around a little bit to do some more
research about this research to get all
the facts first of all the people
conducting the study are not objective
researchers these are activists with an
ideological agenda and this study is
funded by people with an ideological
agenda they are out to prove that
same-sex parenting is fine they actively
want to reach that conclusion now if you
go into a study routing for a certain
conclusion that doesn't necessarily mean
your conclusions are wrong but it does
make your entire methodology and
everything suspect because that is not
the scientific and legitimate way to go
about these things you're not supposed
to want a certain result you're supposed
to just oh what you're supposed to want
as a researcher is to find out what the
result is
it is obviously an issue with the people
conducting a study strongly favor one
conclusion over another second problem
this is not a random or representative
sample
they only studied lesbian parents there
are no men in the study and the
participants are mostly upper-middle
class
employed college educated basically
well-off third problem the participants
all know they're involved in a long-term
study to prove that same-sex parenting
is good the petitioner participants were
in fact eager to participate in a study
like that and wouldn't you know it all
of these politically engaged well-off
lesbian women when asked will tell you
that lesbian women do a great job
parenting kids Wow isn't that shocking
fourth problem the study contradicts
almost everything we know about child
development for example the study found
that these lesbian relationships broke
up at a pretty high rate a higher rate
than than in the national average but
amazingly it also found that the breakup
of these homes had no effect on the kids
you know they all turned out fine which
contradicts almost all research not to
mention common sense
you know which which tells us that kids
and broken homes are at a disadvantage
so summing things up here this is an
ideologically driven study involving
exclusively well-off lesbian women who
know what the study is about there is no
control group there is no economic
diversity represented in the sample and
it relies largely on self-reported data
from people who are both ideologically
and personally committed to a certain
conclusion so this again is just
embarrassing and I would suspect having
not looked at all 80 studies I would
suspect that most of them probably have
one or all of the problems represented
by the two studies that I just shared
with you and I in those two studies are
not cherry picked these are these are
the ones that are often cited the most
considered you know the most legitimate
and so on all right let's move on there
was one other thing I wanted this is
from Jeff says hi Matt caught the stream
of your talk tonight I thought your
speech one of the best I have ever heard
honestly I thought you handled the cue a
very well but I did have a question
about one of your answers someone asked
you if society has an if society has an
anti white bias and you said no that
seems to contradict your past statements
do you just say that because you didn't
want to give any more ammunition to the
idiots asking questions I understand if
so but I was confused by your response
yeah fair question yeah I was asked I
believe that was the exact phrasing was
does society have an anti white bias
pretty sure that was like you have to go
back and look but I think that was how
it was phrased my actual answer was no I
think the bias is based more on ideology
and I stand by that I don't think
society in general is set up to you know
keep the white man down I think that if
you're a white person in our society you
can do quite well obviously and
encounter very little resistance or
discrimination if you toe the
ideological line so a liberal especially
an upper-middle class urban white
liberal I think will have to deal with
very little bias and and will live it
will live
very privileged existence now if he's a
conservative Christian that's a
different story if he's blue-collar if
he's from a low-income area particularly
in the south and so on then there will
be more of a societal bias also remember
something I've talked many times about
the victim hierarchy in society with of
course the irony being that people who
are the most who are who are most
considered to be victims actually have
the most privilege and have the most
sort of social capital that that
supposed victimhood affords them well at
the top of that hierarchy as I have
literally drawn and before you in the
past at the very top LGBT and there at
the top of the victim hierarchy in
society and there are plenty of white
people out there there are even plenty
of white men up there doing doing very
well in terms of how society treats them
now if you want to get more specific and
start talking about specific
institutions then you can start to see a
more generalized anti white bias
affirmative action for example in the
education system that is obviously anti
white bias it so it's it's intended to
be that it is institutionalized codified
anti white bias it's also anti-asian
bias but but even that you know that is
focused more on men than it is on women
so that's how I would break this down I
don't think it's quite accurate to say
Society has an anti white bias I think
society the culture is much more
concerned with ideological conformity
but but the explicit racial bias starts
to creep in much and become much more
apparent in in certain institutions so
maybe it seems like I'm splitting hairs
there but I think that this is an
important distinction and it's important
for us to be specific and how we talk
about this I know many times in the past
I have not been specific about it but we
have to keep this in mind that that the
elites in our society academically it's
people in government Hollywood so on
many of them probably most are white and
what are they up to what's their agenda
are they white people with an anti white
bias no you know that to me is like is
like when a black person comes out as
conservative and then he's accused of
being self-loathing and
against himself I think that's absurd I
don't think the human mind works that
way not gonna be bigoted against your
own group now I think there is this sort
of performative self-loathing thing that
white people can do but I don't think
it's sincere I think these are people
with a white Savior complex and they
want to be seen as especially woke and
enlightened so they pretend almost to be
self-loathing I don't think they
actually are so I think the agenda of
these elites is is one as I said
ideological conformity there are certain
ideas a certain worldview that they're
trying to impose and if you go along
with it if you repeat the lines that
they give you if you follow the script
you'll have smooth sailing
white black doesn't matter as I said a
white person with the quote right
ideology and who says the right things
and has the right worldview and has the
right attitudes about sex and especially
comes from the right socio-economic
stratum will lead a very privileged
existence same for anyone of any race
who falls into all those categories and
one other thing the question if I
remember correctly the question was
about anti white well it wasn't anti
white male
it was anti white I do think that
society is in many ways especially the
education system bias against men
against boys and against manhood in
general but I mean think about a
well-off liberal sexually enlightened
white woman I would say someone like
that is basically going to encounter no
bias anywhere I mean that that's that
that's one of the easiest existences you
can have that's that's one of the
easiest existences currently on offer in
the world is that especially in the
education system I mean our education
system is designed for people like that
in that category and the woman part with
a girl that's that's a very important
aspect of it the education system is
designed for girls and it caters to them
which is why huge coincidence right that
when you find that that boys in the
school system are drugged for ADHD at a
much higher rate than girls why is it
because the system isn't really made for
the boys it's made for the girls and the
boys who are not able to learn like
girls learn
and-and-and-and aren't able to sort of
you know conduct themselves in a similar
way then we just say that they're
mentally disordered and we drugged them
so that again is that is that a racial
thing no I think it's I think it's
deeper than that so that's my point all
right last question this is from Jude
says Matt great show but what's up with
the banjo in the background can you
actually play that sing if so can you
play us a song
well Jude yes the banjo in the
background which I it's usually in the
background but I have it right here
because I was waiting for this question
now first of all why would you even ask
me if I can play it do you really think
that I would have a banjo on display in
my office that I can't play I mean what
kind of poser do you think I am what
kind of poser has a an instrument on
display that they can't even play that
you even asked me that is I'm offended
that you think I'm that kind of person I
mean good no I in fact I can play the
banjo I play it every night for my
family they all gather around and I play
a tune on the banjo
we call it banjo hour all the kids are
excited you know every night there's so
when it's banjo hour it's a whole hour
of banjo it's kind of maybe a little bit
excessive
anyway can i play you a song yes I can I
will look at this bad boy
tuned up here you always go he's got
tune your instruments before you it's
got to get it all tuned up ready to go
now this is an original composition then
I'm going to play for you here you
weren't expecting a musical interlude
for the show but here it is okay go
start playing this song
[Music]
you know I I'm something of a what we
call a minimalist musician it's not
everyone's style it's a little abstract
very it's a very sort of heady way of
playing the instrument really makes you
think
but that was my song so thank you for
giving me thank you for giving me the
chance to share my music with you which
really is my greatest passion in life
and thanks everybody for watching thank
you for listening
Godspeed
the Matt Walsh show is produced by Sean
Hampton executive producer Jeremy boring
senior producer Jonathan hey supervising
producer Mathis Glover supervising
producer Robert Stirling technical
producer Austin Stephens editor Donovan
Fowler audio mixer Mike Cora Mina the
Matt Walsh show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 19
Democrats impeachment attempt isn't
merely a hoax or a witch-hunt
it's a coup and you don't need to take
my word for it that's the word being
used by the lawyer for the whistleblower
who kicked off the latest impeachment
push in the first place
we will blow the whistle on the
whistleblowers coup check it out on the
Michael Noel's show